bonjour
aujourd'hui on va parler de la
philosophie hier
pourquoi parler de la philosophie d'elle
hier bien
un mouvement de pensée qui a marqué
l'histoire de l'europe de manière
profonde c'est un mouvement qui a
véritablement façonné l'esprit
occidental moderne
nous tous aujourd'hui nous sommes en
grande partie les héritiers de cette
pensée des lumières
les héritiers inconscient
et donc s'intéresser à la philosophie
des lumières c'est se donner l'occasion
de comprendre un peu mieux notre propre
mentalité de comprendre un peu mieux
comment nous pensons c'est à dire
finalement comprendre un peu mieux qui
nous sommes
alors pour situer un peu la philosophie
des lumières c'est le 18ème siècle donc
c'est le siècle de la révolution
française
parmi les auteurs les plus connus on
citera voltaire diderot
montesquieu ou encore rousseau
c'est un mouvement qui s'est diffusé
dans toute l'europe occidentale
france en allemagne en angleterre et par
ricochet aux états unis d'amérique
d'ailleurs on remarquera que la
traduction du mot lumière n'est pas
exactement la même selon les pays en
allemagne on utilise le mot à auch les
rings qui ne signifie pas lumière mais
illuminations
de même qu'en anglais enlightened
donc il ya cette idée de diffusion cette
idée de propagation on ne retrouve pas
dans le non français
deux cas la référence à la lumière
renvoie à la même symbolique à savoir la
symbolique de la connaissance
la lumière c'est l'emblématique ation de
la connaissance
on peut le voir dans notre vocabulaire
quand on demande à quelqu'un de nous
éclairer de nous éclairer de ses
lumières on lui demande de nous
renseigner c'est à dire de nous aider à
comprendre
quand on dit qu'un propos n'est pas
clair
qu'il est obscur l'obscurité c'est le
contraire de la lumière donc un propos
obscures
c'est un propos confus c'est un propos
qui entravent la compréhension
on a aussi le mot lucide qui signifie
clairvoyant
si tu ça vient du latin look here et qui
veut dire luire
donc à part de cette simple
interprétation symbolique on comprend
déjà ce qu'est le premier pilier de la
philosophie des lumières à savoir la
connaissance
et lumière c'est le projet de diffuser
la connaissance
et
connaissance c'est déjà introduire un
premier concept qui est le concept de
raison
la philosophie des lumières c'est une
philosophie de la raison
et si c'est 1 temps de commencer par ça
c'est parce qu'à l'époque des lumières
une grande partie de l' influence sur
les esprits est exercée par la religion
plus précisément par l'église catholique
l'église catholique qui à l'époque
détient encore un pouvoir politique
on est dans un régime de monarchie de
droit divin le clergé représente le
premier ordre devant la noblesse et le
tiers état
donc même si l'église ne contrôlait pas
la société toute entière elle possède
néanmoins un pouvoir d'influencé non
négligeable notamment dans le domaine de
la culture et de l'instruction
or pour les lumières l'église c'est
l'ennemi juré de la raison
je dis bien l'église et non pas la
religion
parce qu'il y à des philosophes des
lumières qui ont une religion il ya les
philosophes des lumières qui ne sont pas
apte et
voltaire lui-même n'était pas apte et il
était d east il croyait en l'existence
d'un grand horloger c'est sa célèbre
phrase l'univers m'embarrasse et je ne
puisse songer de cette horloge existe et
n'est point d'horloger
donc pour les lumières la raison n'est
pas incompatible en soit avec la
religion
mais elle est incompatible avec la
superstition
autrement dit elle est incompatible avec
une certaine conception de la religion
une conception de la religion qui
consiste à prêter à dieu une volonté et
plus particulièrement une volonté que
l'homme lui obéisse
on sait que dans la plupart des
religions monothéistes dieu impose ses
lois aux hommes
les dix commandements c'est dieu qui
transmet à moïse une liste
d'interdictions
les sept péchés capitaux
c'est dieu qui défend aux hommes d'être
soumis à leurs vices
et la sanction en cas de désobéissance
on la connaît c'est l'enfer
les flammes éternelles
et ses flammes éternelles sont là comme
une épée de damoclès au dessus des
hommes
pour leur rappeler qu'ils doivent
craindre dieu et lui obéir
et bien ça nous disent les lumières
c'est de la superstition
c'est de la superstition au même titre
que de croire que la foudre est le signe
que dieu est en colère
parce que ça consiste à projeter sur
dieu des sentiments qui sont des
sentiments main
c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'anthropomorphisme
le fait de prêter à une entité non
humaine des caractéristiques humaines
et ça pour les lumières ça tient pas la
route
c'est pas à rillieux
et c'est d'autant moins sérieux qu'on a
aucune preuve de cette volonté divine
on n'a aucune preuve que l'enfer existe
on n'a aucune preuve que tu veux nous
surveille
et qu'il attend nous quoi que ce soit
on peut croire en dieu comme principe
créateur comme cause première
dans ce cas là on est dans une approche
philosophique de la question divine
mais faire de dieu un patriarche à barbe
blanche qui nous surveillent du haut de
sa voûte céleste pour les lumières ça
n'a pas de sens
c'est ça la scission la croyance
irrationnelle
la croyance qui n'est fondée sur rien
d'autre que sur elle même
au moyen âge on
les chats noirs
parce qu'on voyait dans le chat noir un
animal diabolique
aujourd'hui on ne considère plus les
chats noirs comme des animaux diabolique
mais par contre le fait est que quand on
croise un chat noir on y pense
on pense au fait que le chat noir porte
malheur
que passer une échelle porte malheur
que casser un miroir porte malheur
or la notion même de porte malheur comme
celle de porte bonheur puisque c'est la
même chose
elle n'est pas fondée sur la raison
elle est fondée sur la croyance
elle est fondée sur de l'irrationnel
et bien pour les lumières tout ce qui
n'est pas rationnelle nous éloigne du
vrai donc tout ce qui n'est pas
rationnelle doit être combattue
il y as chez les filles des lumières un
militantisme de la rationalité
militantisme de la rationalité ça veut
dire qu'il ya une volonté de critiques
et de dénoncer de tourner en ridicule
les rationalités religieuse et
l'irrationalité des préjugés
quand voltaire écrivait écrasons
l'infâme à la fin de ces lettres
c'était un cri de ralliement des
militants rationaliste contre
l'obscurantisme religieux
voltaire était vraiment à l'avant-poste
de la critique de l'église se moquer
ouvertement des cultes religieux
par exemple dans zadig il ironise sur le
fait de savoir s'il faut entrer dans le
temple de mithra du pied gauche ou du
pied droit
parce que pour lui croire que dieu en
aurait quelque chose à faire de savoir
de quel pied on entre dans un temple
c'est d'une stupidité sans nom
parce que ça ne signifie rien en dehors
de la signification inventés par les
hommes
c'est ça que disent les lumières à
savoir que nos croyances religieuses
sont moins le reflet de la volonté de
dieu que le reflet de ce que nous
projetons sur la volonté de dieu
finalement h fois que nous prêtons à
dieu une volonté et des sentiments nous
l'humanise on est en l'humanise ans nous
leur à besson
pour les lumières le véritable blasphème
ne consiste pas à se moquer des
croyances religieuses
véritable blasphème consiste à projeter
sur dieu nos propres inventions
on parlait à l'instant des superstitions
religieuses
de la foudre qui indiquerait la colère
de dieu
voltaire a écrit un poème qui s'appelle
le désastre de lisbonne
le désastre de lisbonne c'est un
tremblement terre qui a eu lieu à
lisbonne en 1755
un tremblement terre absolument terrible
puisqu'il a fait entre 50000 et 70 mille
victimes
or il se trouve que ce tremblement de
terre a eu lieu le jour de la toussaint
autrement dit le jour d'une fête
chrétienne
dans laquelle on commémore les défunts
comment ne pas y voir un signe
comment pas y voir un message de dieu en
personne
des dizaines de milliers de morts le
jour d'une fête religieuse
cette catastrophe naturelle était en
fait une catastrophe surnaturel
ça c'est l'interprétation
superstitieuse
le cataclysme comme châtiment divin
comme punition du vice humain
sauf que pour voltaire
or ça ne tient pas
parce que les morts de ce tremblement
terre
des innocents
dont des enfants
pour reprendre sa citation exacte je
cite direz vous en voyant cet amas de
victimes dieu s'est vengé leur mort et
le prix de leurs crimes quel crime
quelle faute ont commis ces enfants sur
le sein maternel écrasé et sanglant fin
de citation
provale terre
interpréter leucisme de lisbonne comme
une punition divine
donc finalement comme quelque chose de
juste
c'est absurde
parce que pour que ce soit une punition
divine
encore faut-il qu'il y ait un crime à
punir
en tout cas si on applique un
raisonnement rationnel
parce qu'en l'absence de crime la
punition devient injustifiée
donc 2 l'idée soit dieu n'est pas à
l'origine de ce tremblement terre
soit dieu est injuste
vous imaginez peu pour un croyant
la deuxième option est encore plus
coûteuse
donc par
rationalité ce qu'il faut bien saisir
c'est que pour les lumières rien ne peut
être placée au dessus de la raison
parce que la raison est un arbitre
impartial
parce que la raison s'appuie sur du
factuel et sur du démontrable
parce que grâce à la raison on a pu
expliquer des phénomènes que la foi et
la superstition ne parvenait pas à
expliquer
et quel est ce domaine de l'explication
rationnelle des phénomènes
la science
l'idéal des lumières c'est l'esprit
scientifique
esprit scientifique repose sur
l'investigation rationnelle
sur la démonstration
sur la logique
bref sur toutes ses facultés humaines
qui font que le monde est compréhensible
et qui permet de faire la distinction
entre la croyance et la connaissance
d'ailleurs il est tout à fait logique
pour le coup que le mouvement des
lumières soit apparue peu après les
grandes découvertes scientifiques de la
renaissance
les précurseurs de la philosophie des
lumières
ce sont les astronomes ce sont les
physiciens ce sont les mathématiciens
galilée newton des cartes
tous ces chercheurs qui ont prouvé que
par la raison on pouvait expliquer des
phénomènes qui jusqu'àlors était
considéré comme impénétrable à l'esprit
humain parce que relevant exclusivement
de l'esprit divin
donc
le qu'à l'époque le pouvoir religieux se
soient sentis menacés
par ce que ça signifiait que la religion
perdait le monopole de la connaissance
ça signifiait qu'une autre connaissance
et est possible et qu'elle était même
redoutablement plus efficace que la
connaissance religieuse
parce que tout le monde pouvait la
vérifier
d'où les procès en hérésie
alors ne soyons pas if
le procès en hérésie intenté par
l'église à galilée qui au passage ne
portait pas sur le fait que la terre
soit ronde et sur le fait que la terre
tourne autour du soleil
ce procès n'était pas seulement un
procès religieux
c'était d'abord un procès politique
parce qu'à l'époque le protestantisme
gagne du terrain et que dans son combat
contre les protestants
l'église s'est radicalisée pour bien
faire comprendre ce qu'il en coûterait à
ceux qui chercheraient à la discréditer
d'ailleurs dans ce conflit entre
catholiques et protestants
les philosophes des lumières se
situeront généralement du côté des
protestants
justement parce que le protestantisme
correspond à une vision libérale de la
religion et à une lecture non
littéraliste de la bible
pour en revenir à la science et à
l'idéal de rationalité il faut bien voir
que ce qu'accomplissent les lumières à
l'époque cet univers tab révolution
culturelle
car pour la première fois on disait aux
êtres humains que la connaissance leur
était accessible
qu elle leur était accessible à tous
parce que la raison n'est pas quelque
chose réservé à une élite
d'accord religieuse est réservé à une
élite
la connaissance religieuse implique
d'avoir reçu un enseignement théologique
d'avoir étudié longuement les textes
c'est pas deux tout le monde
alors que la connaissance rationnelle
s'est donné à tout le monde
parce que la raison n'est pas un
privilège de classe
tout le monde possède une raison
tout le monde est capable de comprendre
pourquoi de plus deux égale 4
alors que comprendre la trinité c'est
une autre affaire
donc le soubassement philosophique de la
pensée des lumières
ses skis emmanuel kant appelait
l'universalité de la raison
universalité de la raison qui fait que
même si nous n'avons pas tous le même
niveau d'instruction
ni les mêmes aptitudes intellectuelles
nous avons tous une intelligence
nous avons tous une raison
donc nous tous les moyens de produire de
la pensée rationnelle
l'universalité de la raison c'est ce qui
fait que si une chose est logique elle
est logique pour tout le monde
du moins en principe
et ça ça tant parce que ça veut dire que
par la raison il devient possible de
dépasser les conflits de croyances
personnelles
quand on est dans un conflit de croyance
il n'y a pas de moyen de s'entendre
on est condamné au désaccord
la raison
mais fin aux désaccords parce que la
raison n'a pas d'idéologie
elle n'a pas de religion
elle n'a même pas de morale
c'est la phrase de voltaire dans
l'ingénue reprise par napoléon
il n'y a pas de secte en géométrie
donc grâce à la raison grâce à ce que
les grecs appelaient le logos
les êtres humains peuvent accéder à la
connaissance
ils peuvent accéder à des vérités
là où la religion les laisse au mieux
dans l'ignorance au pire dans l'illusion
et c'est là qu'on soit du rôle
précurseur de descartes dans l'émergence
de la pensée des lumières
parce que des cartes et le premier
philosophe à penser la question de la
connaissance non pas à partir de dieu
mais à partir de la raison
le je pense donc je suis c'est la
première formulation de l'idée selon
laquelle l'homme se définit par sa
raison
et si l'homme se définit par sa raison
ça veut dire que l'homme n'a pas à se
soumettre aux dogmes rationnels qu'on
voudrait lui imposer il n'a pas accepté
des règles de conduite arbitraire ou
absurde parce qu'il est en mesure de
savoir par lui-même ce à quoi il doit
croire ou ne pas croire
le mot d'ordre des lumières c'est pense
par toi-même
ne reçoit pas ta pensée une autorité
extérieure
ne soit pas soumis aux autorités qu'ils
prétendent mieux savoir que toi où est
la vérité
utilises tu as raison
aux l'utiliser
osent penser
au sport
c'est la phrase d'emmanuel kant dans son
livre qu'est ce que les lumières
est pour quand c'est vraiment ça le
socle de la philosophie des lumières
l'autonomie intellectuelle
auto nomos se donner ses propres règles
ne pas recevoir ces règles d'une
autorité extérieure
y compris ses règles de penser
la seule autorité qui doit s'imposer à
l'individu c'est la raison
parce que la raison est une autorité
neutre
c'est une autorité impartiale
et donc par conséquent ce n'est pas une
autorité
pour quand le siècle des lumières c'est
le passage de l'humanité de l'état de
minorités à l'état de majorité
majorité au sens de devenir majeur
d'accéder à l'âge de raison
on dit d'un enfant qu'il n'a encore
atteint l'autonomie parce qu'il n'a pas
encore atteint l'âge de raison
l'âge auquel on peut prendre des
décisions éclairées
encore et toujours la métaphore de la
lumière
donc les lumières nous dit content c'est
la sortie de l'homme hors de l'état de
tutelle et il ajoute dont il est lui
même responsable
et oui parce que devenir autonome
intellectuellement
ça implique aussi de devenir autonome
moralement
autrement dit d'être sponsable
si l'enfant est sous la tutelle de ses
parents c'est parce qu'on considère que
s'il n'est pas en mesure de prendre des
décisions éclairées
il n'est pas non plus en mesure de les
assumer
or le pouvoir religieux et même le
pouvoir politique dans sa forme
absolutiste
déresponsabilise les individus
puisqu'il les infantilise
il les infantilise en leur demandant d'
obéir au lieu de réfléchir par eux-mêmes
en leur demandant de suivre des dogmes
aveuglément sans les soumettre à
l'examen critique et donc sans qu'ils
aient la possibilité de comprendre les
dogues localise obéissent
ce n'est pas pour rien si l'oeuvre qui
symbolise le mieux le projet des
lumières c'est l'encyclopédie
l'encyclopédie de diderot et d'alembert
sous-titré dictionnaire raisonné des
sciences des arts et des métiers le
moins important étant raisonnée parce
que l'encyclopédie allait permettre la
propagation de connaissance jusqu'à
l'heure réservé à l'élite intellectuelle
et donc allait permettre par
prolongement de fournir des armes à la
pensée critique
on ne pense qu'à partir d'un matériau
premier qui est le savoir
donc propager l'esprit critique ça passe
aussi par diffuser à voir
et pour les lumières le savoir à une
importance d'autant plus fondamental
qu'il permet de désamorcer l'un des
poisons de l'esprit critique à savoir le
préjugé
près juger juger avant sous-entendu
avant de connaître
un préjugé c'est une idée admise sans
preuves
et si le préjugé est problématique pour
les lumières ce n'est pas seulement
parce qu'il contient le risque de
l'erreur
c'est aussi et surtout à cause de sa
conséquence à savoir
l'intolérance
donc vous voyez que tous les éléments
s'imbriquent
esprit critique
raison tolérance
tout ça ça va ensemble
parce que le war nous libère de
l'ignorance et donc nous libère de
l'intolérance
et donc c'est la con quoique le combat
des lumières n'est pas seulement un
combat intellectuel
mais que c'est aussi un combat politique
la lutte contre l'intolérance
c'est un combat pour tic
et la forme légier de ce combat contre
l'intolérance ce sera la remise en cause
de la tradition
pour les lumières la tradition et le
véhicule de l'intolérance
alors voyons un peu ça
vous
je parlais de la fameuse querelle des
anciens et des modernes
la querelle des anciens et des modernes
c'est une polémique qui a éclaté au sein
de l'académie française au xviie siècle
et qui a opposé les partisans de la
tradition qui considère que c'est dans
l'antiquité qu'on trouve les modèles à
suivre ce soit sur le plan moral mais
aussi sur le plan artistique
et les partisans de la modernité qui
considèrent au contraire qu'il faut
renouveler les codes qu'il faut
renouveler les pensées les mentalités et
les normes autrement dit qui considère
que la tradition doit être dépassé
il ya un véritable clivage qui se met en
place à ce moment là entre ces deux
conceptions du monde
d'ailleurs on notera que rousseau est
peut-être le seul philosophe des
lumières
se situe davantage du côté de la
tradition que du côté la modernité au
saut est très critique envers la
modernité il pense que le progrès des
sciences et des arts s'est accompagnée
est une dépravation morale
il pense que ce que nous avons gagné en
connaissance ne l'avons finalement perdu
encourager en vertu
mais pour tous les autres philosophes
des lumières la source de nos erreurs et
même la source de nos maux c'est la
tradition
la tradition qui nous enferment qui nous
fait nous replier sur nous-mêmes
là où la modernité nous fait avancer
la tradition nous empêche d'être libre
elles nous imposent les modes de
comportements qui font obstacle à la
créativité et à l'innovation
chez les lumières il ya par exemple la
volonté de promouvoir les différences
culturelles
là où la tradition on va au contraire
promouvoir l'appartenance au groupe
on trouve ça par exemple dans les
lettres persanes de montesquieu
ou dans le dernier chapitre de candide
avec ce personnage du vieux musulmans
qui vit heureux en cultivant son jardin
c'est le début de ce qu'on appellera
l'orientalisme
il y a aussi chez les lumières la
volonté de promouvoir l'hédonisme c'est
à dire la recherche du plaisir
là où la tradition privilégier le
sacrifice et l'abnégation
là encore voltaire est sans doute celui
qui a le mieux exprimé cette facette de
la pensée des lumières dans un poème qui
s'intitule le mondain et dans lequel
voltaire affirme clairement la
supériorité morale du plaisir sur la
vertu
d'ailleurs le poème a pour sous titre
apologie du luxe
autrement dit apologie du superflu
apologie du plaisir et renoncement à la
vertu
citons quelques lignes
j'aime le luxe et même la mollesse tous
les plaisirs lézarde toute espèce la
propreté le goût les ornements tout
honnête homme à de tels sentiments il
est bien d'où pour mon coeur très
immonde de voir ici l'abondance à la
ronde mère des arts et des heureux
travaux nous apporter de sa source
féconde et des besoins et des plaisirs
nouveau lors de la terre et les trésors
de l'undd leurs habitants et les peuples
de l'air tout sert au luxe aux plaisirs
de ce monde oh le bon temps que ce
siècle de fer superflu choses très
nécessaire a réuni l'un et l'autre
hémisphère quand la nature était dans
son enfance nos bons aïeux vivaient dans
l'ignorance ne connaissant ni le tient
ni le mien qu'aurait-il pu connaître il
n'avait rien il était nu et c'est chose
très claire que qui n'a rien n'à nul
partage à faire la soie et lors de
briller points chez eux admirez vous
pour cela nos aïeux il leur manquait
l'industrie et les hans hess vertu
c'était pure ignorance
donc on va bien ainsi que pour les
lumières il ne s'agit pas seulement de
remettre en cause la tradition
il s'agit de remettre en cause toutes
les idéologies de la vertu
toutes les idéologies de la restriction
morale qui font obstacle à
l'épanouissement et au bonheur des
individus
et ce principe de plaisir une idée qu'on
retrouvera plus tard chez freud cette
idée que l'être humain recherche
spontanément son propre plaisir elle
provient directement de ce qu'on appelle
en philosophie le matérialisme
le matérialisme qui veut que rien
n'existe en dehors de la matière que nos
concepts moraux eux mêmes ne sont qu'une
émanation de la matière en l'occurrence
une émanation de notre corps et qui
s'oppose aux spiritualisme c'est-à-dire
à l'idée d'une transcendance
dans une conception matérialiste
tout ce qui touche à la transcendance ou
ce qui touche à un au delà du matériel
est par définition exclut
la fois la vertu l'honneur le sacré ce
sont des valeurs immatérielles
et si ce sont des valeurs immatérielles
ce sont les croyances
des croyances qui n'ont aucune réalité
objective
le plaisir à une réalité objective
le commerce à une réalité objective
la liberté à une réalité objective
et donc de la même façon que les
lumières combattent les superstitions
religieuses
elles combattent toutes les valeurs
irrationnelle issus de la tradition
ont pour seul effet de limiter la
liberté des individus
dont quand on dit que les lumières
combattent l'absolutisme politiques
qu'elles combattent ce qu'on appellerait
aujourd'hui le totalitarisme
elle le combattent au nom de cet idéal
de liberté
n'ont pas la liberté au sens stoïciens
n'ont pas la liberté au sens de maîtrise
de ses passions
mais la liberté au sens moderne c'est à
dire la liberté comme absence de
contrainte
la liberté comme droit de penser d'agir
et de s'exprimer sans limitation par une
autorité quelconque
c'est le fondement de ce qu'on appellera
plus tard le libéralisme
libéralisme politique
liberté d'agir en suivant sa propre
conception du bien
mais aussi libéralisme économique
liberté d'entreprise liberté des changes
liberté de nous et des contrats
commerciaux
sans être mais par l'état
on avait parlé
c'est dante épisode d' adam smith et de
sa théorie du marché un marché libre et
concurrentiel
j'avais mentionné le fait qu'adam smith
admirer particulièrement voltaire
et bien le point de jonction entre la
conception de voltaire et la conception
d'un homme smith c'est la liberté
individuelle
le libéralisme politique de voltaire
c'est l'idée que l'état n'a pas à
interférer dans les conceptions morales
des individus
et le libéralisme économique d' adam
smith c'est l'idée que l'état n'a pas à
interférer dans les affaires économiques
entre les individus
dans les deux cas l'individu est
souverain
quand on parle du libéralisme de nos
jours on a tendance à ne penser qu'au
libéralisme économique
mais c'est une erreur
le libéralisme ça comprend à la fois le
libéralisme économique et le libéralisme
politique
parce que dès lors qu'on adhère aux
principes de liberté individuelle
il n'y a aucune raison le prônait dans
un domaine et de le contester dans un
autre
la liberté ça ne se découpe pas
donc l'idée que le libéralisme politique
et le libéralisme économique serait de
concepts opposés c'est non seulement une
erreur et c'est même une faute
ce sont deux concepts complémentaires
qui participe du même principe de
liberté individuelle
et qui ne diffèrent que par leurs
domaines d'application
donc comprendre la philosophie des
lumières
c'est comprendre le primat de ce
principe de liberté
et c'est comprendre le statut centrale
accordée à l'individu contre toutes les
formes d'interventionnisme
alors certes le mouvement des lumières
n'est pas un mouvement philosophiquement
homogène
entre les penseurs des lumières
il ya des différences et il ya même des
désaccords
mais dans l'ensemble on retrouve
toujours les mêmes principes
fondamentaux
le principe de raison par opposition à
la superstition
le principe de liberté contre toutes les
formes d'oppression
le principe d' individu
considéré comme seule source légitime de
ses choix et de ses actions
ces trois principes raison liberté et
individus
s'intègre dans un principe plus large un
principe qui finalement donne tout son
sens au projet des lumières à savoir le
progrès
et lumière se voyait comme une
avant-garde intellectuelle
qui allait conduire l'humanité vers le
progrès
avec toutes les ambiguïtés et tous les
problèmes de définition que ce terme
comporte
au 18e ecl l'europe est en plein
renouveau
les découvertes de la renaissance ont
considérablement transformé les
mentalités la science a bouleversé ce
qu'on croyait savoir de l'univers
les explorateurs ont ouvert la voie à de
nouveaux territoires
le savoir se diffuse grâce à l'invention
de l'imprimerie
la chimie et la médecine se développent
et tous ces bouleversements vont
contribuer à façonner ce qu'on a appelé
l'esprit moderne
esprit moderne c'est un esprit
d'optimisme
c'est un esprit de foi dans le progrès
de l'humanité
mais c'est aussi un esprit universaliste
un esprit guidé par la volonté de
s'étendre à l'humanité toute entière
pour la sortir de l'obscurantisme
on va sortir de cet état de tutelle
est ainsi céder à la majorité
mais le grand paradoxe des lumières
c'est que leur idéal universaliste a eu
pour conséquence de conduire à ce que
précisément il dénonçait en l'occurrence
le colonialisme
rappelez-vous le discours de jules ferry
en 1885
et civilisation supérieure ont le devoir
d'éduquer les civilisations inférieur
cette phrase nous paraît choquant
aujourd'hui
et dans la bouche d'un partisan du
progrès du 19e siècle
elle fait sens
car dans cette vision
sortir l'humanité de l'obscurantisme
ce n'est pas du colonialisme
c'est une heures
c'est un geste d'altruisme et de biens
ce
faire il et de bonnes mains sue
et il est probable qu'en voulant guider
l'humanité vers le progrès et lumière
n'ait pas pensé un seul instant aux
implications morales d'un tel projet
l'ironie est temps que diderot lui-même
dans son supplément au voyage de
bougainville
fait dire à son personnage du vieux
d'haïtiens
nous ne voulons pointereau qu'est ce que
tu appelles notre ignorance
contre tes inutile lumière
stupéfiants
stupéfiants constater que les lumières
peuvent elles mêmes conduire à
l'obscurantisme
quand elles sont tenu par la certitude
d'elle-même
stupéfiant que le plus haut taux
critique des philosophes des lumières
jean jacques rousseau
et finalement était le seul entrevoir
les limites de cette idéologie du
progrès
à voir que le progrès des connaissances
ne s'accompagnait pas nécessairement un
progrès moral
que nous avons les vertus de nos propres
croyances
et que nous sommes aveugles à notre
propre fanatisme
dès lors que nous sommes persuadés
devrait pour le bien
je vous remercie
[Musique]